the military's actually much better
at measuring trust because
for them it's
trust is life and death right that if
you don't and i've had so many
experiences getting to work with marines
or seals or whoever where the way they
talk about trust
um i'll give you a a a another example
just
so i had the opportunity to visit
quantico which is where the marine corps
selects its officers
uh and i had a briefing by the colonel
in charge of of
of ocs officer candidates school
um and he showed up late for the
briefing now marines don't show up late
you know if you're on time you're late
that's their belief
and um
uh and he showed up late he said i'm
terribly sorry we've had an incident on
base
that we're considering throwing out one
of our students
ending their career throwing them out of
the marine corps
and of course curious george here is
like what happened you know
and he said to me
he fell asleep on watch
and i said
that's it
like he fell asleep on watch in the
woods of virginia and you're gonna throw
out of the marine corps
and he
i like you guys are pretty tough
he said no you don't understand he said
when we asked him about it he denied it
when we asked him about it again he
denied it again
and when we gave him irrefutable proof
then he said i want to take
responsibility for my actions
and the problem we have is you take
responsibility for your actions at the
time you perform your actions not at the
time you get caught
he said we had another marine who fell
asleep on watch he owned up to it
immediately we punished him and we have
no problem with him
and then the colonel went on to explain
to me so you have to understand if i
take this person and i put them in a
leadership position
and if his marines doubt for one second
that their leader is being honest with
them
or if if his marines think that he's
doing something just to advance his own
career
and protect himself at the sacrifices of
his marines trust will break and people
will die
and so when in a combat situation when
there is chaos
and by the way
command and control is not uh is not a
leadership uh um
mentality or philosophy that you can
engage on a regular basis and it's not
so in the military but it is essential
in chaos covet is a great example like
when we went into covid that was chaos
every plan went haywire everything went
haywire and you do need leadership that
does actually go into command and
control
but the thing is that command and
control only works
when you have spent time building the
trust up until that moment because when
i tell you to follow my orders blindly
don't question me just do it there has
to be the undying belief that you're
making this decision for the right
reason and you're not going to
needlessly sacrifice me and i know that
you will make mistakes so the marines
know that mistakes will get made and
people will die because of those
mistakes but we're not doing them on
purpose and we're not needlessly
sacrificing people and they will follow
those orders blindly now that's an
extreme example because it's the marine
corps and it's life and death but the
same is true in business which is you
can't command and control all the time
that's micromanagement and that wears
people out
but but good leaders who are empathetic
and spend the time building trust and
care about their people in chaos in
crisis they have the opportunity to
convert into into short-term command and
control and it's highly highly effective
and the team comes together in
remarkable remarkable ways but the trust
has to be built first